I live this country this city for 47
years I come over from Japan no money
meet the real mr. Miyagi Fumio de Mira
damira was Miyagi stunt double in the
Karate Kid films and his training
methods have inspired much of the karate
culture we are familiar with today he
credits his dojo in Santa Ana California
for much of his success
dojo me is not just a studio not just
fighting development they're human
beings that reason we call dojo the
karate legend has been training martial
arts stars here for nearly half a
century but his iconic dojo might not be
around for much longer this place is so
many people go through October 3 Chuck
Norris and the Steven Seagal de Mira's
dojo rests on a busy section of Bristol
Street a major gateway into Santa Ana
the city plans to add extra lanes to
ease traffic as part of the Bristol
Street widening project
city officials claim they need to Mira's
land as well as eight other neighboring
businesses for the project and they're
threatening to use eminent domain in
order to acquire them that's the
government's power to take private
property for public use
being able to increase mobility is the
main goal it's just a very important
roadway arterial here in the county
Santa Ana Mayor Miguel Pulido has been
leading the project since its inception
in the early 90s it's just a very slow
process you have to deal with every
single homeowner every single business
owner but if it's well planned and it's
well done ultimately it makes a better
city we respect and we understand the
necessity of the transportation project
to the city and we want to participate
in the road widening we understand the
need for that we're not saying don't
widen the road what we're saying is work
with us Cristina rush represents the
Bristol Street businesses she says that
back in 1991 the original plan required
a hundred and twenty feet for the
additional lanes this would allow for de
Mira's dough
Joe and most of the other businesses to
remain but a revised report came out in
early 2013 suggesting an extra 30 feet
for landscaping which would make it
impossible for the businesses to stay
what we're asking the city to do is
eliminate that unnecessary feet 15 feet
of Parkway from each side of the roadway
we can give you that in our plan through
our landscaping through architectural
elements outdoor seating we can achieve
what the city wants that Park like look
while still allowing the businesses to
retain their properties and their
businesses at their current locations
I'd have to stay much as I can you go
this is the or the house I we fix it so
hard-working we're trying to figure out
you know what can we do to work together
to accommodate the street widening and
to hopefully if we can reach an
accommodation to have the businesses you
know continue to operate as businesses
they should only acquire so much as they
need access acquisitions are unnecessary
and often are part of the abuse problem
Chapman University's Donald cotton
specializes in property rights and
eminent domain he's skeptical that
negotiations alone could change the
current plan there is precedent for
eminent domain abuse there are a lot of
motivating factors that encourage the
government to exercise eminent domain
power the incentives to appease interest
groups to increase the tax base and with
very few checks on eminent domain power
Cochin says the best hope is community
support business owners win when they
can capture the hearts and minds of the
public to the extent that you see a
public backlash if this doesn't work the
businesses might have no choice but to
shut their doors and just accept
whatever compensation the city offers no
the offers haven't been fair they're
they're way below market value
unfortunately just compensation does not
take into account some of those more
owner specific values such as the loyal
client base that they've built up over a
long-standing period of time people know
where we are for example either day I
get the mail
Santana California karate studio that's
it the America mean people know where we
are even below market value needlessly
acquiring these properties is a
substantial expense an expense that
taxpayers are on the hook for it
involves significant costs in the
project itself and the taxpayers are
going to have to fund that cost not only
will they have to pay but the fact that
these businesses have been open on
Bristol Street for so long is proof that
they are highly valued and it'll be a
huge loss for the community the
community has definitely shown that
these businesses are integral to their
functioning because they come to us
we've been here for 25 years we've been
paying for this we've helped the
community it's our right to stay here if
it does come to you having to leave do
you think you'd start over I got a
choice I had to move someplace but I do
again